en ce moment c'est comme sait le faire
et à défaire le monde photo de poche lui
montrent tout leur argent et des montres
cristiano ronaldo chine montre à 500000
euros
je crois qu'il ya une certaine décence
qu'on met la france va mal le monde va
mal il est parti vit pas en france
le monde va mal en général il ya
beaucoup de pauvres a été peint de choix
à bord et qu'il dépensera gens très bien
ils font marcher la dignité puisqu'on
veut arborer des montres à 500000 quand
la plupart des gens n'arrivent pas à
finir mais moi je me sens un peu
indécent voilà qui m'a lancé argent très
bien mais à me disent que ce n'est pas
le seul à montrer qu'ils aiment le luxe
de plus en plus de stars ont dit étalent
leurs richesses regardez vous à résumer
tout ça
les nous dire ce que vous en pensez
juste après et vous aussi est ce que ça
vous choque voilà les stars qui
affichent leur richesse c'est parti on
va vous avez envoyé quand on est une
star et qu'on gagne des millions il ya
deux façons de se comporter
la première c'est de la jouer vie privée
et mystère pour protéger leur carrière
et éviter d'attiser la haine mais pour
d'autres réussite rime avec faire savoir
et les réseaux sociaux sont une occasion
en or pour étaler leur richesse c'est le
cas par exemple du footballeur cristiano
ronaldo qui une fois n'est pas coutume a
décidé d'exposer autre chose que son
slip sur les réseaux sociaux le champion
a choisi d'exhiber à son poignet une
montre pas comme les autres surnommé ice
cette rolex d'exception est estimé à 450
milles euros prochaine folie pour le
champion se faire un slip en diamant
peut-être et il est loin d'être le seul
à montrer sur les réseaux que même après
les fêtes son compte en banque se porte
bien comme par exemple kylie jenner qui
n'a pas hésité à pourrir de cadeaux sa
petite stormy son cadeau de noël une
bague en diamant stone en même temps à
un an
on rêve tous de ça dans la famille
kardashian kim a aussi fait des folies
en offrant à sa fille north âgée de 6
ans une veste et un chapeau ayant
appartenu à michael jackson un cadeau
d'une valeur de 60 mille euros et 6 aux
etats-unis ces pratiques sont légion
depuis longtemps en france ce sont les
stars de télé-réalité qui ont adopté
cette mode affiché sans complexe une
réussite financière c'est le quotidien
de nabila qui n'a jamais caché son cadre
de vie privilégié
même chose pour jazz et laurent qui
forment sur les réseaux la dgi et si
family des comptes qui regorge de photos
de piscine de bijoux et de voyages alors
les stars qui affichent leur richesse
sur les réseaux sociaux choquer ou pas
choquer la craie la 4e vitrine détruite
gagnez bien votre vie vous le méritez on
croise dans la rue vous attend sur m en
trottinette ben voilà ça c'est dit voilà
oui ça c'est des sens si on peut pas
gérer mais honnêtement moi j'ai fait une
erreur quand j'ai commencé la télé
j'avais pas de honte à gagner de
l'argent tu as fait qu'une on est
sincèrement j'ai fait l'erreur j'ai dit
je t'ai content jamais j'avais estivale
âge je suis content je suis fier une
ferrari veine ashton ça m'a été reproché
mille fois la différence je trouve au
contraire on gagne de l'argent ces
patriarches de le dire et de montrer ce
que je ne supporte pas c'est qu'on passe
de la mode le coup face à la morale aux
autres - cas footeux bon moment une
rolex à 450000 euros
c'est son voyage il gagne très bien sa
vie quel est le problème à l'instant
n'en qu'elle est nommée cessenon quel
est le problème je comprends que ça
choque la somme évidemment coc hors de
prix montent à ce prix là mais en même
temps il mbouda l'enquêté qui fasse mais
de quoi moi je préfère un mec il met sa
montre et qui a su king pognon que celui
qui dit non j'ai une kelton et qui m'ont
en 2010 soit ça m'horripile ça il faut
être honnête tu es du pognon tue le
montre notre pays où tout le monde peut
acheter l'amour à 450 me et pas faire un
poste avec la photo de la soupe et
matthieu delormeau non pardon tu
confonds de choses tu confonds aimé
avoir aimé montrer si aimé montrer
mais voilà ces gens là je crois que
c'est même pas le fait d'avoir une monde
qui lui fait plaisir c'est le fait qu'on
le voit et pour lui c'est un signe de
réussite et les gens qui regardent
on associe la réussite à l'argent et
c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a eu c'est la réussite à de
mauvaises valeurs parce qu'en général je
veux pas prendre les zombies série les
p'tits tard et ce avec moi même et a
réussi une jolie voiture tu as vu de tel
musée avec amuse toi
en revanche ces gens là lui monsieur le
but c'est même pas la conduire c'est de
montrer qu'ils n'ont eu et il est là le
problème il est là le problème
merci c'est comme c'est quand il ajouté
c'est comme vous avez envie de montrer
que vous allez m'avoir vous n'aurez
jamais mm mais oui un non mais c'est
vrai moi ce que je dire qu il voulait
parler d'abord non mais bon c'est bon il
préfère yoann toi le cas échéant dure
onze années passées de là là là
messieurs je peux pas vendre sur le
rythme va pas vous parlera après le
générique mamie tu vas là mais si tu
veux arrêter de me hurler dans l'oreille
non mais c'est vrai ça il va et ses sens
et la différence philosophique entre
l'être et le avoir après mathieu je te
trouve un peu faux cul oui marrakech
c'est quand tu es au ski et que tu es
talent quand même ça aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux on dit bien que t'es pas
au rsa est une blague marrakech à
m'écouter 1225 duo voix ont valu pour
tout gérer
mais c'est bien mais si tu dire que ces
énormes de sang dit pas le contraire
mais c'est ce que tu rates sur instagram
qui monte des vacances n'est pas en
train d'étaler ton pognon là c'est la
seule manière c'est à ta manière les
violines cristiano ronaldo il touche 850
1000 euros par poste
c'est l'homme le plus le sportif le plus
le plus payé dans le foot
moi ça me choque pas effectivement il ya
un truc qui a changé aujourd'hui ces cas
les réseaux sociaux ouais avant quand on
voyait ces gens là on acheter ou pas
paris match
point de vue images de monde jour de
france ont regardé ça alors
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans son salon on
a du mal à finir ses fins de mois et on
est on voit dans le salon cristiano
ronaldo ses rolex et ferrari et tout ça
est forcément c'est obscène forcément ça
crée de la frustration
forcément ça crée des jalousies mais moi
j'estime qu'il a pas volés qui fait
aussi plein de gens parce que grâce à
cette économie là réagissez sur twitter
l'atelier joie idée joaillier des gens
qui travaillent dans la mode des
coiffeurs et je trouve qu'ils
participent aussi à la rivière il avait
lui-même isabelle réserver les acteurs
redemande le visa belle vous appelez
zabel je suis sincèrement
du côté de mathieu juste aucune
différence entre assumer sa richesse et
l'a montré et l'étaler parce que la
gamine convoi qui a une montre qu'il
doit coûter je sais pas combien de
centaines de milliers de dollars s'est
d'ailleurs pas un bon c'est pas un bon
exemple à monde c est tout et puis quel
c'est une façon de dire regarde regarde
effectivement donc c'est ses autres os
et beaucoup 3 ces gens là vivent dans un
monde parallèle c'est pas assumer sa
richesse
c'est bizarre tu gardère s'est
littéralement dans un monde où al alawi
lerner et quelques passes a réussi son
montant permet gens là sont très
attachants et 13 de rome mathieu
vraiment bien sûr c'est ok on a on va
demander à quelqu'un qui est en
difficulté en ce moment de donner son
avenir est bon bah moi je moi je trouve
qu'il est requis je vais y arriver
non moi je trouve voilà qui est qu'ils
aient ça tant mieux pour eux après ce
que je trouve bizarre c'est de montrer
avec des postes et en plus ils ont
retouché dollar et free rencontre il
faut pas oublier que soient chanteurs
footballeurs acteurs n'importe qui les
gens qui vont les voir pourquoi ils ont
gagné tout cet argent c'est que des gens
qu on crevait de faim ou qui se
défoncent pour aller payer les concerts
pour aller payer les places au stade de
foot c'est des gens qui ces maillots mal
et on leur rejet d'ivoire les maillots
trouver des maillots de foot les plaines
et place au stade et on leur dit regarde
la lavette 60000 euros fait autre chose
avec son ami cristiano ronaldo y joue
une très modeste il a été parfait gradés
dont chirac dit les miens oui je parle
pas de pression nous la question c'est
est-ce que ça vous choque qui montre moi
je préfère qu'on le découvre nous mêmes
c'est à dire je regarde je fais toi
c'est quoi ce truc et sans internet et
rogatoire dans le sac tant mieux ça qu
on va découvrir les maris femmes
artistes nominés alsac s constructeur s
i
il ya beaucoup d'effets quand il ya
beaucoup d'arguments on peut se dire on
va prendre un peu de là et là
effectivement on voit ce qui pourrait
juste un peu me chaut qu'effectivement
c'est une bague en diamants un bébé si
ça raconte en fait ce qui là je trouve
ça d'un trait démesurée après
effectivement on peut pas lui reprocher
aux gens de voyager ça je pense que les
voyages après après après il ya plein de
gens qui sont en train de dire sur
twitter il faut single belge
c'est un faux regardez les twittos sera
pas tous choqués 47% pas choquer la
moitié 53% voyez c'est plutôt oui mais
c'est plus de l'autre côté je croyais
que voilà
mais en tout cas c'est plus sympa choqué
que choquer oui à la défense d'eads est
footballeur le jeu
[Rires]
excepté les loubards aux autres outils
magistrat
dutoit dire que lors des ventes aux
enchères en tout cas il ne se prive pas
d'acheter des choses extrêmement cher
vers 16 heures et ça ils peuvent le
faire aussi
sa tâche est une oeuvre d'art bien sûr
c'est comme chip 400 ils montrent que tu
avais payé tu la donnes et j'aime aller
merci annoncé ne rendons pas l'argent
vulgaire si matthieu delormeau 2006 oui
à la juge m pour finir quand les vous
demandez aux gens qui rêve d'avoir
il reste à voir ce que les gens montrent
effectivement alors entre nabila et
ronaldo c'est pas pareil pour moi y'a il
ya un grand champion qui a réussi et des
télés mais alors inhabitée afghane mais
non mais je vais pas les gardiens à
raisonner non mais c'est pas ce qu'il a
dit mais c'est deux choses différentes
après ils font ce qu'ils veulent de leur
auzen x qu'est ce qu'un solide manquer
ça je rêve d'avoir quand une petite
grille de loto il à vous répondre
une ferrari c'est la première chose qui
embrouillent je sais que si vous gagnez
beaucoup d'argent vous allez acheter des
lunettes
voilà travail par exemple mais c'est
vrai que la décharge moi c'est vrai que
je suis en famille s'est pas fait des
fautes de goût du sapin de noël voilà
comme on dit la première chose pour lui
quand tu gagnes au total ce sont des
gens c'est une ferrari mais c'est pas
vrai